[Music]
all right welcome back to another
exciting episode Kos and today I can't
wait to get all patriotic on you guys
that's right hold on one second let's
light following subscribe hit that
notifications so every time Kara West
pops up you can get the latest videos
that's every week your boy is bringing
you these statues now let's let's do it
a little bit to get this unboxing video
right so I'm gonna give you the unbox
and I'm gonna give you the particulars
about this statue and we're gonna go to
breakdowns the plus and the minus --is
of this statue and then I'm gonna give
you the MCU knowledge of the statue
right so what our further ado I bring
you the iron patriot now this statue is
a maquette from sideshow and I like the
statue for what it brings to the table
you know what it brings to the table is
brings you that dynamic pose that USA
USA feel you know and on a different
take on Iron Man now we all know when
the iron patriot comes in that's the
heavy guns you know Tony Stark is sleek
in the small
but the iron patriot which is Rodney
Rhodes his his buddy roadie in the movie
played by Don Cheadle himself you know
and I think Don she did a great job not
too many people know that that role was
switched from the first movie to the
second movie but I also believe that you
know they made a good move you know
because the MCU there's a great work
when it comes to that so this statue the
base is impeccable the the plate that it
comes with it comes with a nameplate
and I think that all sideshow or all
statues Chicago the main place for you
know the statute that's being presented
at the time I think it adds an extra a
little bit to it I don't care if you
have multiple statues with the same name
change the nameplate around but I
believe the nameplate was a bonus a plus
that made me jump in and purchase the
statue
plus the place the price point was
amazing I think I paid four hundred and
sixty dollars for it Premium Format
maquette from sideshow oh and this is an
exclusive version which comes with to
switch out heads it also comes with a
stand for the second switch out head
this base also lights up there's two
ways to do it we can do it with triple-a
batteries or they supply a DC plug in
cable for your statue and the reason why
this is such a huge bonus is because in
your statues sometimes you don't want to
leave the batteries in their batteries
tend to rot corrode and devalue your
statute and you won't even know let's
say you forget that it doesn't have a
light-up feature but if it's plugged in
with the DC cable you won't have any
form of corrosion at any point in time
so I believe that is a huge plus when it
comes to this Premium Format maquette I
love the polls
I think it's dynamic enough I think it
has a lot of light up positions the
chest lights up both hands like
sup and the eyes light up this statue is
definitely worth the price of admission
it's worth it if you're an Ironman fan
if you're down with the Ironman law and
you like Warmachine you like the iron
patriot and you are fan of that universe
especially if you're a fan of the MCU
the statue is worth it
now the down point is I'll show you the
second head I don't believe that they
captured the skin tone of Don Cheadle
well I don't believe that they captured
the eyes well I will not be displaying
this second exclusive head as the
primary feature of the statue I won't be
displaying this head the secondary head
you know with the gate closing the eyes
lighting up because I believe that is
exactly how I walk my I am patriot shown
oh the only thing is missing here is the
American flag so going in to this statue
I was so pleased because when I saw it
was still available and they have free
shipping a sideshow plus I had $25 off
and then I had reward points that I had
accumulated which was over 200 of some
change I really got this statue at a
scale even though I did pay probably
less than $100 for the statue but I
would have got the statue because it is
a value it can fit inside any veste
believe it can fit inside you your PAC
system
this statue is I'm really pleased with
the paint applications is outstanding
the lines are clean
I implore you to continue to watch the
video because at the end I let the video
play showing you videos and pictures of
the statues up close and personal
without this guy talking so let me give
you the difference now listen recently
Sony and Disney and Marvel came chat
disagreement with spider-man and now in
the comic books the iron patriot is none
other than
spider-man's nemesis Norman Osborn I
said it right the Green Goblin is the
iron patriot in the books it was first
introduced in Dark Avengers number one
that storyline went after civil war and
all the heroes broke up and they went
away and Norman Osborn with his
diabolical mind felt that it was time to
start a new initiative so what he did
was he got a bunch of Dylan's and they
all were in the guise of Avengers he had
bullseye like Hawkeye you had bacon
which is Wolverine son as dark Wolverine
you had Ares playing the role of either
you can say Thor or Hercules you had
venom playing but filling the role of
spider-man and you had a lot of these
characters that are villains that wanted
to be on this Avengers team because they
were going to get their criminal history
wiped clean and Norman Osborn was the
iron patriot see now an MCU Don
Cheadle's the iron patriot because they
own the rights to that so they was gonna
use this character which was highly
anticipated in the MCU to their
advantage and they had a nice way to
work a minute you know they took away
the boring war machine and took away the
bland colors of the gray
and the silver and they gave him the red
white and blue that flag and he also had
a way to bring it in so I thought that
it was an ingenious way for the MCU to
use a character that they could know
they couldn't really use that before
they got to deal with spider-man
remember Don Cheadle donned the suit
before the deal was done with spider-man
to bring him to the MCU and he never
talked about Norman Osborn at all so we
still got the iron patriot and right now
with the deal with Sony and you know
Disney we don't know what's going on but
the iron patriot stakes so this is a
time in the video where I'm going to
tell you guys to like follow and
subscribe don't know how it goes and
also go to Lords of gaming dotnet you
can get all your information all old
iron Lord podcast shows old Kos shows
also combat talk of the king and the
last word with low kognito and avanti's
there they are talking all that loot a
shooter stuff and right now destiny is
going nuts the dlc is about to drop the
division is all hot apex legends is on a
riot and you you have Borderlands that
is actually tearing these streets up
when it hits you got people were already
probably making queues ready for that
game I'm telling you Twitter is going
nuts with Borderlands I'm playing the
old one now so tune in till next week
and I'm telling you right now I have a
custom statue that is being shipped to
me as we speak
and I've waited for this custom statue
for two years
I'm going to try to bring you my best
production for this statue it is going
to knock your socks off this is a Holy
Grail piece there's only 50 of them in
the world 25 of the version that I have
and 25 of an alternate version that I
will go over in next week's video see
you guys next week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]